I assume Jeffrey Epstein was mobbed up
with intelligence I you know yes I think
so I think it's almost guaranteed and
will the intelligence agencies allow
that information out that's a good
question that's a fair question I mean I
I think it really does depend like what
what was this guy we really don't know
like what this guy was doing like James
P I read I actually read James
Patterson's book on the on the thing you
the big mystery writer and he's you know
he's a billionaire so he does he write
his own books even I don't no no way but
but he gives people credit for writing
them you know but um I read it and it
didn't tell you anything except like you
know what he would do to these women and
I thought come on what the hell was he
up to